well it's been one year since Nevada
state trooper Micah May was killed in
the line of duty the 46 year old was hit
by an impaired driver during a chase on
the I-15 well now law enforcement
agencies across the state are coming
together to remember him and keep
everyone safe on the road Sasha Loftus
filed this report earlier tonight
he was definitely my rock one year after
Nevada Highway Patrol Trooper Micah May
lost his life his wife Joanna shares
what she loved most about him he was
very funny very witty and extremely
smart Trooper May died in the line of
duty on July 29 2021 when an impaired
driver hit him during a chase on the
I-15
officer on Friday family friends and law
enforcement gathered to honor him and
mark the start of an annual Statewide
initiative his life was taken from us
from an impaired driver and so it's just
that much more special to us that we go
out there and we save lives Nevada State
Police Trooper Ashley Wellman says the
goal of the may you choose not to drive
impaired campaign is to get drivers who
are under the influence off the road and
keep others safe today is truly
Bittersweet but the beauty in the
tragedy is that we've all come together
all while remembering the man Micah May
was behind the batch he was an amazing
husband and father and supporting those
he cared for most every single day I
I'm so grateful that Nevada Highway
Patrol actually stuck to their guns and
is there to help us when we need them
Sasha Loftus live local now